today's topic invader v now you guys may
not be aware but a twitch streamer by
the name of
vader v was on stream and basically
gotten a little incident that caught the
internet
by storm it doesn't really matter how
much money you make or how much money
you have
that's really the thing because i'm not
asking you for a
large financial contribution if it cost
twenty dollars to sub twenty dollars is
quite a bit of money
twenty dollars is you can get a full
meal for twenty dollars
and the difference of twenty dollars and
eating a meal is in that twenty dollars
like that's where it is
but a sub is five dollars at maximum
in whatever your currency is it's maybe
ten dollars
and it doesn't matter how broke you are
if you have time to watch twitch
you have you have ten dollars truly if
you
don't have ten dollars you probably
don't have time to watch twitch because
you should be working
you should be trying to earn money uh
it's not a ton it's not like a ton of
money
so being like i'm broke i can't afford
to sub it that doesn't really track
what you mean to say is i'm so
irresponsible with my money
i can't support the entertainment that i
enjoy
that oh my so here we have some
excellent 300 iq comments from the
peanut gallery
this conversation sucks this is weird
yikes these are exquisite contributions
to a very good conversation
and these people in chat who are making
these comments do not appear as immature
childish cheapskates whatsoever
they're just sitting here mastering as
hard as they possibly can
as quietly as they can because their
parents are in the next room talking
about how disappointed they are in them
and they're like why would i ever pay
for this when it's just let's giving it
away for free
you're right buddy you're right any
thoughts
she does because she can we were talking
about risk
the other day in the podcast
when you put yourself out there and you
decide
to do what we do put our opinion out
there
response messages it comes with a lot of
good you know
getting other gigs being recognized and
stuff like that
but it comes with a lot of bad you know
getting insulted
whether it's on the comments or in the
inbox every day
doing all this
should i have a price we should be paid
for what we do
but there's a risk of us
not getting paid for what we do
you have to accept that it comes with a
job i mean
we have a patreon if you want to go on
the patreon
thank you very much appreciate it
but i would feel very bad
to this people that are not contributing
this is the name of the game you
contribute or you don't
it's your choice i wouldn't go on the
cam and be like hey
if you don't give me your final super
counterproductive
super entitled but she can so she does
she's talking about yeah dude these
people don't want to get a job in this
and that blah blah blah and you're gonna
your parents are
what are you doing you're doing the same
thing boo boo
i like how she's shaming people for not
giving five dollars i'm like why do you
need the five dollars
you're in the same position as them okay
well she put out a little apology
okay well she put out a little apology
if the apology is more than five seconds
long
i don't want to hear it you're here
right now because you've seen a clip of
me
and you're very angry about what i said
in that clip
and you're justified in your anger
what i said was tone deaf insensitive
and stupid and i recognize that
no your money's hurt baby that's all i
hear my money's hurt and i need to go
back to
my status i can only own what i said and
i will
the clip that you saw does not represent
my true feelings
yes it does it represents who you are
what you say
when you thought you weren't getting in
trouble
is you but it's okay
with all due respect why didn't you
apologize before the clip blew up
okay um
oh that's that's
if you i
that's a difficult question to answer um
preemptively talking about
a bad take quite often for a lot of
streamers will highlight it more
than if they let it lie so so you are
more concerned with it disappearing
instead of apologizing for what you said
um
let's okay there have been other there
have been other
statements that i've made on stream that
have been questionable if you stream for
any amount of time eventually
you'll put your foot in your mouth the
problem isn't that you put your foot in
your mouth i think most people agree
that yeah
you make enough videos eventually you're
gonna say something stupid you're gonna
say something that
the problem is you apologize once the
heat was on you not because you were
actually sorry
so you deflecting with this was kind of
astonite but okay
so this is what our stream normally
looks like i am not a mouse i am a kitty
yeah jeez come on guys and legs are
amazing
is that enough is that everything that
you've ever wanted anymore more than i
could have asked for
you're welcome sean only for ten dollars
you got that whole leg those shoes are
obnoxious
and they match me just right then
they're just perfectly fine for me then
this is what she looks like now yeah
cause she's apologizing
okay this is so phony it's marketing so
phone it's good
like trying to make yourself look like a
sympathetic person
covering up all your skin all of a
sudden making your stream look different
your body language all like
hand in front of here talking so softly
as if now you're being submissive to the
crowd
it's interesting how everything is
shifted for this apology
i love the way that in sympathetic
they're simping it
now let's put something sympathetic here
people have criticized her you know for
doing this during a quarantine for
shaming this and that
here's the thing having went through a
lot of her videos some of her streams
looking at the chat even during the the
initial video you'll realize that
everyone is
like her chat's making excuses for her
they're just like hey we understand
even on twitter they were making all
kinds of excuses like listen all she was
trying to say is that
people don't want to give money because
they don't want to not because they
don't have it
okay no way to know that yeah but that's
not what you said though
what i suspect is that this is how she
always
engages with her fans in a very
condescending manner didn't you see like
the posture that she had
when she was in that original video the
awkward laughs that she was doing
really track what you mean to say is i'm
so irresponsible with my money
i can't support the entertainment that i
enjoy
and these people in chat who are making
these comments do not appear as immature
childish cheapskates whatsoever
it's just like posh condescending thing
that she does
that's her act and within the realm of
her
twitter feed or her twitch feed that's
what they go there for
guys are paying money she's like show us
a bit of leg and they throw money and
they're like thank you that's more than
i could have ever asked for
they like being talked to this is some
weird fandom
it's not weird it's weird to me what she
said originally
it wasn't meant for everyone but
everyone else saw it so you basically
walked in on someone
having a fetch kick and you went this is
disgusting why are you guys doing this
when you didn't realize this wasn't for
everyone to watch the problem is she was
doing this on the open platform
for everyone to see that's the real
problem it's kind of like dark humor
really dark humor yeah it's meant to be
done in a certain context
it's kind of like when arie shafir just
posted that joke about kobe bryant to
twitter with zero context
right just put it out there that joke in
a comedy club would have passed but in a
context like we saw it there
it doesn't work as well this is a little
bit of that same thing
her fans are not mad about it the people
that she was talking to are not mad
about it but the people who ease dropped
were the ones who really got upset
does that make sense so i can't get mad
because there's simps out there
and sims likes what she does and so sims
will forgive her and they will keep
throwing money at her
because they want to invest i probably
guarantee you this is going to drive
more revenue to her
more simpson be like i kind of agree
with her i can't wait to give her money
this is great publicity for her that's
good i suspect
i could be wrong but i think in the long
term it'll be good for her because
at the end there's just too many sims
out there who are ready to forgive a
pretty girl
who talks to them like she does that is
the reality of this world
so i know a lot of people wanted me to
come in here and like slam on her but
i'm like
there's no comment that's that's the
demographic of what she's speaking
exactly
that's what it is i would never be
caught dead in that chat she would never
speak to me that way
but i'm not her clientele i'm not the
one who's in her
twitch feed it's her fans were there all
this to say
these are my thoughts on this topic uh
do i think it's good to shame people for
money of course not i would never do
that
you know we don't do this on this
channel y'all can enjoy all this content
for free we'll always make it for you
for free
and then if you guys want to pay a
little extra there's extra content
that's the way we function
we'll only shame you if you announce
your exit
yeah i hate that well i can't
just leave don't let that door hit you
in the back of the head especially if
you
say that you would unsub a couple of
videos later
you still hear trashing you're a fan
yeah and it's okay yes admit that you're
a fan yeah
in some industries all publicity is good
publicity this is one of those
industries yeah
these are my thoughts on this topic um
otherwise
yeah i don't think i have anything else
to add anything you want to say no no
[Music]
cool
bye